the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
tonight on politics now rising inflation
and war with ukraine we're joined by
senator catherine cortez masto wooing
latino voters the efforts by both
parties to court one of nevada's fastest
growing voting blocks and
i'd like to just talk about the
packaging and the
quantities
well we see pot lounges finally open in
nevada the licensed details being worked
out and the new projected date for them
to open
[Music]
from eight news now this is politics now
[Music]
thank you for joining us here on
politics now i'm john langler and we
start with a request from governor steve
sisilak this week he asked clark county
prosecutors not to prosecute a man who
verbally harassed him outside of a local
mexican restaurant it was caught on
camera of course in a statement the
governor says i feel an obligation to
avoid further fueling and at worst
glorifying the anger and violence
plaguing our nation and our state a
trial should it occur he continues would
cause further coverage and provide this
small minority of nevadans to more
opportunity to spew their vile
nevada's senate race is one of the most
watched in the country republicans think
that catherine cortez masto's seat is
one they can win but the democrat says
she thinks that she can keep her job we
started a discussion with the war in
ukraine
what can we do and what should we be
doing well what we can do is what we are
doing is the unity i i think it is so
important that the united states be
unified with nato countries with the eu
um in holding russia accountable
we are at a juncture right now where we
have a ukraine which is an independent
sovereign nation
is being invaded illegally by russia we
have innocent civilians
women and children who are literally
being killed and murdered
and so we need that unity to make sure
that we continue to supply support for
humanitarian aid for military aid
we need to make sure that we're united
in our sanctions i've always felt that
we needed crippling sanctions against
russia against their financial system
against their
elites like their oligarchs and
including putin to [ __ ] them so that
they do not have the finances they need
to fund this illegal war a couple of
weeks ago we had the people from nevada
hand here and they were talking about
you mentioned affordable housing and the
issue of section 8 vouchers
comparing
las vegas and southern nevada with
chicago population is roughly the same
the amount of vouchers up there
completely different than here what
efforts are you making in washington to
try and address that issue well first of
all let me just say nevada has been an
incredible partner of mine
i've been able to work with them in the
senate they've informed a lot of the
legislation i've worked on to
incentivize
affordable housing building happening in
in the state and they've done fantastic
work because of my conversations with
them i'm very familiar of this issue
with respect to vouchers that's why
we've tried to increase the number of
vouchers and the work that i've done
through legislation in banking and
housing committee to increase the number
of vouchers so we have more of them here
in the state of nevada it is about
vouchers to help section 8 but it's also
about workforce housing we have people
in this state who are are working
with the police officers or they're
working in healthcare you name it they
can't afford a house
the prices are too high so the goal is
how do we incentivize building
that can lower the cost of the housing
and that is something that not only have
i've been
working on have done already some of
that to get more of that incentive here
but there's more work that that we can
do that i have introduced in in the
legislature we just saw you know a
protest a rally earlier this week
downtown regarding tip allocation rates
and the changes for all of the workers
here in town has a big effect as you
know uh
why do you think
uh that change needed to happen what can
be done to try and alleviate some of the
pressure on these workers well first of
all the change shouldn't have happened
irs should not have increased and change
the tip allocation
what they should have done is actually
reached out and talked with the
hospitality industry first
here's why the hospitality industry in
the state of nevada and across the
country whether it's
a travel tourism convention space live
events we were the hardest hit during
this pandemic if you recall we had 30
unemployment in this state i mean i'm
third generation the strip was closed
i've never seen that people were going
down to the strip to take pictures
because nobody's ever seen that we were
the hardest hit and we're the last to
come out of this we are still challenged
because we don't have our international
traveler back we don't have our a
business traveler back a hundred percent
the last recession we have i was the
attorney general that's when i went
after the the big banks and made sure we
were doing everything we can to help our
homeowners here in 2008 when that
recession hit it took us seven years to
come out of that in the state
that's why when the pandemic hit the
healthcare pandemic hit when i as i've
been in the senate my focus is after
living through that making sure we had
covered relief that was coming into our
state to support individuals and
businesses so that when we opened our
doors again we could spring back much
quicker and we have that's a good thing
but we still have more work to do you
don't believe that it was too much put
into the system one of the issues with
inflation one of the issues someone
suggested with the economy is that there
was almost too much
money pumped in and now it's it's sort
of thrown everything out of balance on
the other on on the back end well tell
that to the uh
several states and counties that we have
here our rural counties and our urban
counties that needed that support tell
that to the businesses uh because of the
hospitality industry that we just i just
talked about that was so hard hit that
still needed to support the unemployment
workers here
in the state that still needed that
support it was important for us in
and for me to make sure that
our voices
in congress particularly in the state of
nevada that's revenue is based on
hospitality industry and travel and
tourism and the many people that work
here that their voices were still being
heard
you can watch our full interview with
senator catherine cortez cortez-masto
including the discussion on fighting
inflation more of that and ukraine and
interviews with her republican opponents
adam laxalt and sam brown that's all on
eightnewsnow.com just look for the
political news tab
the 2022 election filing deadline
meanwhile it is over one area we saw
some last minute surprises is in the
congressional races let's start with
congressional district one where
democrat dena titus is the incumbent she
drew a new republican challenger former
congressman in cd4 crescent hardy he
will have to beat latinos for trump
leader carolina serrano in a primary
titus meanwhile is facing a primary from
challenger progressive amy viela in
congressional district two danny
tarkanian decided he hasn't had enough
yet now douglas county commissioner
tarkanian has lost multiple bids for
office including congressional races
over the past two decades now he's
trying to primary incumbent republican
mark ammaday
jumping over to democrat stephen
horsford's congressional district 4 seat
the republican field looks a little
different now champion boxer jesse
vargas has decided not to run instead
focusing on his boxing career and that
leaves assemblywoman annie black sam
peters and chance bonaventura to fight
for the republican bid there
horsford had some unwanted publicity
this week his wife started posting about
his affair and she posted on social
media in 2020 horsford admitted to an
affair that lasted 10 years here you see
on twitter his wife sonia douglas doctor
sonia douglas horsford posted that she's
been quiet for two years you can see
here she was saying quiet for two years
that's not and that's enough however
douglas says she and her children are
not enjoying the pain they're suffering
since he filed for reelection she added
in her twitter posts she will not be
silent this election cycle
once again both parties are lobbying for
votes from latinos and latinas here in
southern nevada the primary is in june
christian cousins went out to look at
the reference
are you registered to vote the countdown
is on to get southern nevada residents
registered to vote for the upcoming
november midterm elections
pop-up sites like this one for the gop
on the corner of eastern and bonanza is
hoping to grow their latino base
but residents say this election will be
different because many are tired of
unfulfilled campaign promises
molina says she is voting for a change
and not for a specific candidate what we
continue to sell is the republican
values and principles particularly for
hispanics they really identify
themselves with the party that
defends
freedom and opportunities democrats not
wasting any time and pushing their own
message natalie hernandez with make the
road action nevada has been an organizer
for 10 years she's been fighting for
immigration reform since her father was
deported in 2011. i used my story i used
other stories like mine to help keep
people motivated and let them know that
like this isn't a fight that we're gonna
win in one two three four years both
parties tell us residents can expect
more outreach as election day gets
closer and a great chance for latinos to
address concerns like immigration and
the economy the violence and
everywhere there's a lot of killing in
there
all over the city christian casarez 8
news now
we have a link so you can register to
vote or update your information on
8newsnow.com pot lounges are one step
closer to opening here in nevada before
anyone can apply to open a lounge the
cannabis compliance board has to finish
all those regulations joe mohler was at
a workshop this week to go over those
rules
i just think 48 hours and two work days
contradict there were suggestions and
then questions so you will allow private
companies to come in and do the private
training for those establishments okay
nevada's cannabis compliance board
invited the public to go over the
drafted regulations for the future
cannabis consumption lounges i'd like to
just talk about the packaging and the
quantities that we're doing they went
over all aspects of the industry from
serving sizes and packaging requirements
to training for employees the
application process was discussed right
now 10 licenses will be awarded for
private stand-alone lounges 10 for
social equity applicants to increase
diversity in the industry then unlimited
for dispensaries looking to add lounges
i'm eager for the state to move forward
but i also want it done right
i appreciate the slow roll aisha goings
is the founder of the cannabis equity
and inclusion committee she says she
wishes the social equity applicants were
for nevada residents one of the things
that i'm disappointed with but just
can't be avoided is the fact that the
social equity licensing will be made to
all social equity applicants across the
land
i really wanted that to be focused in
the nevada space a lot of public comment
came from people in the industry i think
we got a lot of good feedback to make
the next steps with the lounge ring
board director tyler klima says this
will make it easier in the future allows
us to flush out all aspects of both
licensing and operations of the lounges
so there's no surprises and it puts us
in the best position and puts the
program in the best position to succeed
joe mohler 8 news now
klamas expects one more workshop to go
over these final changes he says some
applicants will get approval by this
fall
next on politics now sparks fly in
confirmation hearings we'll talk about
accusations by republicans about supreme
court nominee katanji brown jackson plus
building its own brand north las vegas
mayoral candidate robert taylor tells us
his vision
588-4800
welcome back to politics now
as many as a hundred thousand refugees
from ukraine will be allowed into the
u.s this week the white house also
announced in addition to that a billion
dollars to support countries in europe
helping ukrainians escape the war on the
russian invasion president joe biden was
in brussels this week working with
allies to try and bring new sanctions
against russia he has also met with
poland's president
sparks this week on capitol hill the
senate judiciary committee held
confirmation hearings for supreme court
nominee katanji brown jackson
republicans attacked her sentencing
record saying she was soft on crime
especially on child predators
i think you're doing it wrong and every
judge who does what you're doing is
making it easier for the children to be
exploited for every person in all of
these
charts and documents
i sent to jail
south carolina senator lindsey graham
you just heard from and texas senator
ted cruz faced criticism from democrats
they went over there a lot of time and
frequently interrupted judge jackson's
answers
substantial supervision
you think it is a bigger deterrent
answer a question
you can bang it as loud as you want i
can just tell you at some point you have
to follow the rules signs of behavior
joining us to talk about the
confirmation hearings as you see is alex
simone from our washington dc bureau uh
alex what's been the response from judge
jackson and the democrats to these
criticisms that she was soft on crime
there were even allegations that she
left let child predators off the hook
interesting stuff on capitol hill
yeah judge jackson addressed those
allegations head on and she said that
for every one of these examples that
republicans had these are people that
she sent to jail and then democrats also
mounted a strong defense of her pointing
to publications like the national review
which as you know is a more conservative
legal publication well the national
review called these
you know attacks from republicans
disingenuous and meritless to the point
of demagoguery and so democrats say that
these allegations don't really hold any
water in fact the
fraternal order of police has endorsed
judge jackson and so what what was left
out of this conversation during the
hearings is the the larger national
conversation that's happening around
sentencing guidelines a lot of judges
all around the country even conservative
judges are leaning towards sentences
that are on the lower end of sentencing
guidelines and sometimes even below
those guidelines because of this
national conversation about whether
sentencing guidelines are too punitive
and whether they're unfair toward
minorities you know historically many
times we've seen that minorities get
much tougher sentences for the exact
same crimes uh compared to their white
counterparts and so that larger
conversation is something that was sort
of left out of these
hearings altogether
speaking of the hearings what happens
next what is the timeline for the
confirmation hearings
well now that these hearings have
wrapped up in the judiciary committee
the next thing that's scheduled to
happen is a vote by that committee
that's scheduled to happen on april 4th
after that the nomination would then
move to the full senate senate democrats
are hoping to have a vote before
before mid-april before they leave
around easter for a couple of weeks they
will be leaving washington
and that was alex limon reporting judge
jackson also said she would recuse
herself from an affirmative action case
involving harvard where she is on the
board of overseers
next here on politics now a new identity
for north las vegas
office of pride
mayor mayoral candidate robert taylor
talks to us about why he's running for
mayor and his plan to get more tourism
to north las vegas
now
you're watching politics now
the last couple of weeks we've been
looking at the mayor's race up in north
las vegas right now there are seven
candidates to replace john lee who's
running for governor one candidate is
businessman robert taylor he owns the
fademall barbershops there are many in
north las vegas taylor is also known in
the community as twix
what has motivated you to go from the
business world into the political world
well a big run for mayor
it is a business you are the mayor
you're part of the council and the city
is a business so that's a correlation of
being a businessman and being one of the
reasons of las vegas i feel like there's
a void of certain things that need to
happen and i've been feeling voice my
whole life so i'm running to fill in
that void
what's the void
well a sense of pride like i feel
northwest has been a little brother of
las vegas forever it's time for us to
grow up
how does north las vegas grow up if
you're elected mayor
if you elected as mayor
a few things one i want to get something
that
causes tourism in north las vegas we
don't have anything for tourists you
know and
we need to have more industrial
businesses and more cyber security
businesses and a sense of identity we
don't have a skyline we don't have a
sense of identity so that those are
things i want to bring in to the city of
las vegas you haven't been in politics
before you have a lot of businesses up
in north las vegas so for the viewers
who maybe aren't familiar with you
tell us about your background and and
what's brought you to this point so
uh i'm 44 years old right now and at the
age of 23 i uh bought my first
barbershop for the mall barbershop on
300 east lake mead ever since then i've
obtained six barbershops five salons a
lounge ultra lounge a photography studio
and a
used clothing store called brand news
and with that i've always been big with
giving back to the community so i'm not
just a business owner it's an epp and
flow once you're able to make money and
you know so-called be successful you
have to give back to the community so
this whole time i've been a void filler
for my community for doing free haircuts
for back to school i did free
photography pictures for seniors during
pandemic when everything was shut down
even though my shops were shut down i
opened it up and did free pictures for
the seniors i do school drives not just
for students but for teachers for their
supplies because they have a small
stipend to have and after that you know
pretty much they're out of their school
supplies so i'll raise money and give it
to the teachers all across the valley
even lord city to teachers who need it
so i feel like
my whole my whole time i've been given
for the community so what better way to
do it than be a mayor whoever wins would
become the first black mayor of north
las vegas ever
you were talking a lot about talking to
the community why do you or do you
believe that is an important
component to have in the mayor's office
to relate to and and be able to
understand what is happening in north
las vegas
and the challenges that you think that
it that presents very important you said
in fact if our elected or a few other
candidates we would be the first black
mayor in nevada's history but for the
record i'm not running to be the first
black mayor that's history i'm going to
be the best mayor in the battle of
history for everybody that's what my
barbershops are called fade them all
because i care to everybody and me being
a black person if i were to win that
just shows nevada is moving forward and
we have a great city that that it
shows diversity the john lee
administration has talked a lot about uh
the water line up to apex and some of
the big industries that have come up
near the speedway the amazon facilities
and so forth
where should the priority be in the
mayor's office for getting business
going in north las vegas it's a plethora
of things it's everything it's
one i mentioned small businesses right
you have to get them going they have a
small business incubator right now which
is good a lot of people know about it so
i'm literally doing forums to explain
people how they can get that money for
the small business incubator and this is
for the city of las vegas so once again
it's information a lot of people don't
have the information so you have to give
people the information so we can make a
plan
we have the entire interview with mr
taylor on eightnewsnow.com and the
interview we did a week or so ago with
pamela goings-brown another one of the
candidates for mayor north las vegas
you're never far from findlay you're
watching politics now
this week two new federal judges were
confirmed for nevada they are clark
county district court judge christina
silva and professor antram from unlv's
school boyd school of law
those two seats on the federal bench
have been open for years silva was
confirmed 50 to 46 trom 49-47 both
recommended by senators catherine
cortez-masto and jackie rosen
nevada senator nevada governor beggar
pardon steve sisolak honored former
eight news now anchor polly gonzalez
this week part of women's history month
in a tweet you see there he recognized
her time that she spent
mentoring young hispanic students
interested in careers in journalism
paulie was of course an award-winning
journalist here at channel 8 the first
latina evening news anchor in nevada she
died in a car crash the day after easter
back in 2005. she left behind two
daughters who did survive the crash
this week in what to watch a vote on
judge jackson alexander limon says
democrats are targeting an april 4 vote
on her supreme court nomination judge
katanji brown jackson
if not a vote would probably not come
until after the easter break
in the city of north las vegas holding
its state of the city address current
mayor john lee says he'll talk about
progress up at the apex industrial park
and some of the worldwide brands that
are expanding into north las vegas that
speech will be thursday march 31st and
we'll have coverage of that coming up
later on
thank you for watching us here on
politics now of course stay up to date
on all the political news online at
8newsnow.com and watch us every saturday
right here on eight news now thank you
for joining us